do you think there's any chance that
trump pulls this out
i do one hundred percent really
yeah i think the supreme court the
supreme court has i have been talking
about the fact that this election was
going to end up in the supreme court
since february
you can go back and watch my um um my
interview with the daily caller it might
have been early march
um and i have said this is this is the
most rigged election just looking ahead
at what was down the pipeline in terms
of what we were how we were
fundamentally transforming our society
i expected there to be a lot of fraud um
and i expected that trump would appeal
to the supreme court
um so at the end of the day this is
going to come down to whether or not
they are able
to prove and not just prove but be able
to communicate what they are saying
about the fraud
um i am sorry i don't care if you're on
the left if you're on the right
if you believe that joe biden secured
the most votes
like that that there was more energy for
joe biden than there was
for barack obama in 2008 you're kidding
yourself well
wouldn't the argument be that it was an
anti-trump vote what nobody was excited
about biden but they were interested it
wasn't it just it's not even it wasn't
because
it wasn't an anti-trump vote you know we
know that 30 of people didn't even
bother voting
right so despite the fact that we are
completely submerged in politics
not all of america is right so for me
it's every day is day in and day out but
i also know that my cousins that live in
the projects
couldn't give us stuff about anything
that i do and my cousins literally
i went to eat with one of my cousins um
her name's mia and i'm like we i was
talking about brexit and she was like
what's brexit i want to hang out with
her i want to hang out with her
i'm sitting in l.a everybody talking
about politics i want to go hang out
with your cousins in the projects
tomorrow
and i said i said i said mia it's you
know the brits left the european union
and she goes what's the european union
yes and i was like i love you yeah i
love her too
i love her too by the way i want to go
hang out with her do you do you
what explains and i mean you have a huge
part of this i think i tweeted that i
said candace oh it's a huge
f now the black conservative movement is
very no
it's not covered by the media at all and
you're the biggest voice in it but
there's tons of people out there coleman
hughes whatever it is a lot of different
people
and the media ignores this like it's not
happening
and some of the most interesting
conversations
that are happening online are are
black conservatives that are talking
about
uh american policy and and and
disagreeing and
and and it's very very interesting trump
made gains
with minority voters you know what do
you think
explains that because we've had the most
strenuous year
for race relations probably in in in
that i can remember
and donald trump is very volatile figure
gains
with minority voters what would you
attribute that to
people like me independent voices uh
people are not
buying it anymore and and goes back to
what we talked about earlier the fatigue
of victimhood i mean if if you weren't
tired of being just black this year
when everything oh you're struggling you
know you're just being black i mean
at a certain point i kept saying black
america is going to wake up to this game
you can't just keep doing this every
four years and popping around and then
black lives matter black lives matter
disappearing like a magic act and then
jumping back in you know for the next
election cycle
eventually black people are gonna get
smart um and and that's what's happening
you know we're having conversations we
have our own platforms this is the
reason why the left
is ignoring us but at the same time
pushing for social media censorship
because it's problematic when people
like canis owens can gain you know
millions and millions
of followers and you know they are no
longer relying on the mainstream
narrative
about race right they have another
option and that option sounds a lot
better than waking up every day
and being miserable just because of the
color of your skin and seeing yourself
as a victim like it's
it just feels better i have a better
product right you get to go out and be
happy and live your life and you can do
anything you want because this is the
greatest country in the world
versus you are a victim permanently a
victim your life is going to suck
forever because you were born with brown
skin
but i think it's i think it would be
fair to say
that black people face a different set
of challenges than white people
they they you know in many in many cases
right
and that specifically well i think that
if you look at where i grew up i grew up
in long island and long island a lot of
my
friends were able to inherit homes
because their parents got loans
after world war ii or their grandparents
got loans after world war ii
to buy these houses and they created the
suburbs i think a lot of black people
were excluded
not only from those loans but also from
like those communities like realtors
that
showed black people houses would be
threatened and it was like
so the suburbs and the house which
seemed like the the engine of wealth for
a lot of middle-class families right
building equity in something
ownership if black people were excluded
from that so i feel like
there is a little bit of catch-up being
played certainly if there's not
because it doesn't explain or account
for the reason that black americans
during my grandfather's time did better
than black americans during my father's
time
so that defeats your entire argument
right well there was ownership
so what happened from you know the 1950s
through to the 1970s that black
americans became
more impoverished you know uh owned less
homes
and became more reliant upon the
government structure and the truth is
is we married the government welfare and
now whether you want to argue whether or
not that was strategic and whether it's
the fault of the government and lyndon
baines johnson
uh you know for proposing the great
society act which is what married black
women to the government
that's an argument you can have but you
can't say it's because there's this
long-standing
black american just couldn't break away
if you look at the 100 years following
slavery
black americans did well the fact that
black americans performed better
economically under jim crow laws than
they are doing today
you just cannot point to a systemic
racism
it has to do with choices the choices
that we made to marry the government
and the fact that we cannot out-think
this government structure that you know
black americans still believe in the
victimhood and we'll take the handouts
that black americans will take to the
streets and demand
you know aoc right now is saying we need
to make sure you know black and brown
people the government pays them to stay
home
well hello welfare policies that you
know were the first in that couple black
america in the first place
that they're being reintroduced right
now under covert 19.
so i always see right now we have a
choice right now if we're going to give
another
100 years to black poverty by all the
saying yes to more government handouts
we don't need government handouts that's
the biggest issue is more and more and
more from the government the government
is not
our parent it's not our mother it's not
our father it was an attack on the black
family
um but if we don't wake up to that we're
never going to get ahead black
people make the worst decisions out of
every um
out of every group in america and and
you can compare us to who
who is the most successful group in
america it's not white americans so
your argument about you know white
americans is it asian
it's asia i forget who it is is it
asians
asians indians do well indians do well
i'm irish we don't we don't we haven't
done great
yeah so nobody wants to talk about
asians because it you know it defeats
all the arguments well why people had it
easier
because no one's going to say asian
people during world war ii were japanese
people were internment camps
right well that should be the title
right about white americans today
the title of your next book should be
nobody wants to talk about asians can't
buy candace i know exactly
yeah i do understand but as as a white
person i always say to myself i was a
druggie i drove around
i did not get pulled over nearly as much
as my black friends
i feel like they 100
are more likely to get pulled over and
more likely to go to jail
and we're doing a lot of the same things
right i was uh
you know irresponsible reckless human
being
and i just feel like i maybe had i
definitely had
certain advantages that put me in a
better position
versus uh a kid you know just the idea
that i had money for a lawyer so if like
if there's a black kid who got caught
smoking uh blunt and went to jail um
and he went to jail and my parents could
maybe get me a lawyer to get me out of
it
that to me is it's easier being white
than if that's the
right but here's what's wrong you just
brought up a good point and then you
racialized it
okay rich people yes yes economic
privilege is a real thing it didn't
happen because you're white
right so it didn't matter if you think
that puff daddy's son
is not going to be better off being
pulled off if he has pot
right than some poor white kid you're
wrong but you've accepted the argument
that because of the color of your skin
not because of your economic
circumstances right because of your
economic circumstances
oprah winfrey doesn't have any offspring
but i'll guarantee you that if they ever
got into trouble
they'd be able to get out malia and
sasha obama who we know like to smoke
pot good you know
good for them they're you know they're
enjoying their uh teenage years
right they are not going to go through
the same things that a poor
white trash kid is going through stop
racializing
people have more privilege do you think
that's common sense do you think we
should legalize
weed so that we don't have this crazy
drug war that's putting people in jail
no no i mean listen i i i i have to
think through those arguments more
because i do think
that first and foremost i i think
conservatives that
pretend like pot is the worst thing in
the entire world
are just completely crazy and out of
control um but
the issue is the slippery slope argument
and we know that's real because right
now in california what are they doing
trying to
um with a heroin and methamphetamine
they're trying to make it so you just
get a ticket and keep going so
the problem with the left is that you
never just stop at one thing you're not
like okay you legalize pot and they're
going to be done
right they're like already in california
pushing for decriminalizing
methamphetamine and heroin
and and this is now an argument that we
have to fight so it's hard to find what
the right answer is
when you know that it's it's never
enough to do one thing meaning
a couple years ago it was all about just
gay marriage just gay marriage
i mean the second the supreme court
passed gay marriage we were on trans
rights and we it's been
shoved down our throat uh and now we're
at kids picking their gender and
bathroom signs need to all
to be all inclusive and men name tampons
in their restroom
so i mean i i don't know where i stand
on it completely because i i understand
but isn't there a little bit of
a you know listen slippery slope
argument certainly makes a lot of sense
but isn't there so much pain happening
because
of non-violent drug offenders being in
jail for so long it's disproportionately
affected
people that are as you said economically
disenfranchised lots of them happen to
be black and hispanic
i just feel like there's so much pain
there's so many real world consequences
to that particular law that we should
especially when
it is legal and criminalize it yeah it
is legal in certain parts of the country
people are becoming millionaires yeah
okay so criminalizing is different than
saying
making it legal um and and i agree with
you i think we spend a lot of time
you know the idea of anyone being in
prison for smoking pot is just
ridiculous